welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Frances rosenbluth deputy provost for
the social sciences and faculty
development at yale university professor
Rosenbluth is a comparative political
economist with research interests in war
and constitutions Japanese politics and
political economy and the political
economy of gender the author of numerous
articles and book chapters professor
Rosenbluth has written several books the
politics of oligarchy institutional
choice in Imperial Japan Japan's
political marketplace financial politics
in contemporary Japan and Japan
transformed political change and
economic reform today will speak with
her about her newest book women work and
power the political economy of gender
inequality welcome professor rosenbluth
thanks for having me so what is the
premise of your book this book is about
the political economy of gender and what
we attempt to do in this book is to
excavate reasons for why women have
lower status than men in politics
economics and society and it's it's
common to think about this problem from
a number of angles for example exploring
the reasons behind gender stereotypes
and unfavorable views of women but in
this book we are putting aside for now
the unconscious bias that people may
have towards women and focusing instead
on structural reasons in the economy and
in politics for why women do not achieve
the same levels of prominence as men ok
so why hold aside the bias and
stereotypes well we're not arguing that
these things don't matter that they
don't exist but we are trying to explain
why they have come to be the way they
are so in a sense we're trying to
understand why gender norms are the way
they are why are women view too
currently from men and so we do that
with the standard tools of political
economy okay and what are those tools
and how can they help explain why
patriarchy has been so prevalent
throughout the world for so long the
standard tools of political economy are
begin with basic micro economic analysis
of the marketplace and in particular we
focus on labor markets we try to
understand why efficiency concerns
efficiency considerations by
corporations by employers may lead them
to avoid hiring and promoting women at
the same rate as men and how that in
turn leads to a lower demand for female
labor than male labor which translates
into weaker bargaining power by women in
their family unit where the female is
earning less money than the male and
therefore has to put more emphasis as
well as effort into keeping the family
going as a unit because she can't rely
on her own remunerative capacity her own
money making capability she really needs
a male patron to ensure her livelihood
okay and in doing your research what
countries have you looked at this book
is comparative it focuses mostly on the
developed world rich democracies but we
also at the beginning of the boat take
it all the way back to prehistoric times
to give a very long overview of females
at status of females relative to males
in human society and you start actually
with the hunter-gatherers and things
seem to have been a little bit different
back then than they are today right so
the the data we have for understanding
hunter-gatherer societies is of course
very imperfect incomplete so we're
relying primarily on physical
anthropology
who have uncovered various kinds of data
including the size of bones or artifacts
as well as anthropologists who study
hunter-gatherer societies today these
are not perfect examples of
hunter-gatherer societies as they must
have existed because they have been
contaminated I suppose you could say by
their contact with modern developed
societies but hunter-gatherer societies
as far as we can say we're more gender
egalitarianism the reason we suggest is
because females in those societies were
able to raise their own food sources
they weren't hunters primarily they were
there were gatherers but the food they
gathered the legumes the you know fruits
and berries whatever they were
collecting from their environments for
their families seem to have accounted
for almost four-fifths of the caloric
intake of those early societies and the
fact that they were able to provide
their own food and those for their
children if necessary in the absence of
a male patron made it possible for them
to consider the possibility of leaving a
unsatisfactory relationship with a male
ok so here we are today why do you think
that men have dominated the world for so
very long we focus on the change in
relationships between men and women that
occurred principally with the onset of
sedentary agriculture and what the
establishment of fixed communities did
was to put a premium on male brawn the
ability of males to till intensively the
land often with the help of livestock
and to protect the food or the community
that was fixed in a position and to
protect the stored assets of the
community so this led to a division of
labor within societies within
families where the male specialized in
the production of food female
specialized in the care of children and
any kind of work they could do that was
consistent with continued care of
children this isn't to say that females
don't also engage in agriculture and I'm
sure you know that in the developing
world women do a lot of agriculture so
male Braun did not push women out of
agriculture all together but when the
work that women do is part of a family
unit a family enterprise a family farm
she is not mobile she cannot take her
investment in those skills and move them
to another family because she is really
rooted her assets are in that family ok
so do politics and government policies
influence the gender gap certainly
governments can do a lot to help us wage
that the problems that females face in
weak bargaining with in modern society
but some of the policies that
governments enact to try to help women
have unintended consequences that may
not be helpful so for example here's
here's something that was paradoxical to
me as I was studying this problem you
think about the welfare states in Europe
and the fact that they protect labor
they raised the floor under under wages
and given that women tend to be
clustered at the bottom you would think
that this would be a very female or
gender friendly thing to do it has the
paradoxical effect of increasing the
cost to an employer of hiring a woman if
a woman is nonetheless more likely to
interrupt her career to take care of
family and to do family work so the fact
that a company has to have a long term
contract with a woman has to hire her at
a certain minimum
rate of salary means that they are
required to pay a woman more than her
productivity or her contribution to the
company may warrant if the cost to the
company of her career interruption is is
less than the cost to a company of a
man's employment which is continuous and
uninterruptedly and if we if we look at
today since women and men are arguably
equally equipped in the labor market do
you think male domination in the United
States is now the result of a cultural
phenomenon perpetuated by this very long
history of it being that way I think
that there is a lot of cultural inertia
and so although we are no longer in a an
agricultural society a lot of the norms
that we espouse unconsciously are left
over from an earlier period so I do
think that's true to a certain extent
but I also think that norms gender norms
in the United States and elsewhere have
changed quite a lot so that we can
expect better treatment now than our
ancestors even a few generations ago
sure sure so why study gender inequality
well I think although we've come a long
way there's still quite a ways to go so
it's partly just to try to unpack this
puzzle of why despite the fact that we
espouse these these goals of equality
it's so hard for us to to have real
equality and this book is an attempt to
make an inroad into that question okay
wonderful and I can't help but conclude
the interview today by asking you do you
think at any point in the future that
women would rule the world rule the
world probably not but be more equal
certainly I hope so
okay I'm wonderful thank you so much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your research thank you very
much for having me for more information
about professor Rosen blue and her work
please visit our website at yale edu
backslash macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you